LaDainian Tomlinson hall-of-famer and FL
Network analyst you can see LT every
Sunday on NFL gameday prime at 11:30
Eastern on NFL Network and Fox
good morning LT how are you I'm great
I'm doing okay and I'm curious I wanted
to have you on because running backs
we've seen now back-to-back weeks where
there's been a play where a running back
is using his helmet lowering his helmet
Sony Michele last night Kareem hunt in
the previous week are they going to
enforce this you know it's I think for
running back is the hardest thing to to
kind of get out of your game because the
natural reaction for running back as we
get ready to embrace contact is to lower
your hand and because that's that's what
we've been taught and so I think maybe
there's a grace period for hunt impacts
that they're giving us but yeah yeah I
think eventually they will they will
start calling those calls but right now
I think it's so difficult to take a
plate you know like Sony Michels or
creme hunt it's hard to take that play
away and throwing the flag you have you
saw these guys that you know this guy
who Sony Michelle here it got knocked
out of the game and it's at some point
they got to give the defense a carrot
here a biscuit
LT well they've been giving them
biscuits you know you know for me you
know I think I know you probably talked
about the hits on the quarterback you
know that those kinds of things but man
you know for the most part defenders can
do whatever they want to running back
you know they can you know pour their
helmets and a lot of times you don't
even get the call and there are so many
things that defenders do to running
backs I feel like you know and this is
obviously my personal opinion of being a
former running back that you know no one
no one calls the calls against a running
back you know but that wasn't bad yeah I
mean there did you think I mean I
thought that was
I thought that was just in an act of a
play Nonie
you know they collided and the guy was
kind of coming from the side so that's
it wasn't like they were going straight
up head up you know what I mean and so
the angle that the defender was coming
at I can see why they didn't make that
call as far as the running back position
goes is there a is what is the
traditional running back position now
what do you have to be at what are you
asked to do as opposed to when you first
came up well you know I think it depends
now because you know they got these day
they got running back spot committee
right and so it's become such a
specialized game dance where you know
you have a running back for a specific
reason you know you may have a guy that
can come out the back field and catch
balls Allah James White well we saw last
night and then you got the selling
Michaele guy that can that can carry it
first and second down that you can give
him 18 19 carries and kind of be that
thumper that you need throughout the
game but it becomes such a specialized
game you know when I play which wasn't
that long ago think of all the guys that
we had at that time that got the ball 20
times a game and we were four time backs
we did everything well remember when
gaining a hundred yards was a big deal
now it's a big deal like now if somebody
gets 100 yards you go oh my god back
when you played like a hundred you was
given 150 you had a great afternoon now
if somebody gets a hundred yards we go
oh my god you see you know Nick Chubb
got a hundred yards right because the
guys don't get that opportunity as much
anymore you know it's all about the
passing then and you know the funny
thing things have switched so it's like
if it got those four 300 yards oh that's
no big deal
you know even for the owners know it's
switched now because of the rules and
all the throwing that we have in the
National Football League now and I've
said this before you know it's really to
me it's basketball on grass
and then okay it's okay because the fans
like it but that's what it is to me now
football basketball and grass LaDainian
Tomlinson Hall of Famer joining us Dan
Patrick show also when we look at
running back numbers for the Hall of
Fame the passing numbers are gonna be
different in what we consider for the
Hall of Fame and it feels like with the
running back now I think your catches
are gonna be just as important as your
rushing yards LT you sure absolutely I
think we have to look at the totality of
you know yards for running back I mean
you you look at what a guy like Alan
Chimera is doing if he keeps this pace
and there is no question he's gonna be
and going to the Hall of Fame based off
just his receiving numbers alone catches
you know the dynamic you know athlete
and player that he years through the
passing game not so much his rushing so
yeah you're right that's the way we're
gonna have to start looking at running
backs in the future what do you think of
Le'Veon Bell strategy to announce a
month before his return and right before
the trade deadline that he's coming back
with Pittsburgh yeah you know I'm sure
with strategic I just don't know why do
it now you know say you're coming back
you know in a month or so you know but
hey I certainly get the reason why he's
doing what he's doing he believes is
obviously preserves his body but also
maybe gives him a chance at that big
contract with somebody else but at the
same time why do it at this point
because everybody in that locker room in
Pittsburgh locker room I'm sure it takes
them off because you're saying oh you
know you you feel our pain and and you
wish you were here but you're not coming
back for another month and so everybody
in that locker room I'm sure is pretty
ticked off that he came out and said
that at this point yeah I understand
what he's trying to do but that doesn't
mean as a teammate I have to be happy to
see him come through that door what I
mean wouldn't you have a problem with
that well you know I think
no if I would then I'm not sure you know
I guess it just depends on how much that
God meant to to our team but he doesn't
want to be in there though he doesn't
want to be there he sort of wants to be
there I think he wants to be there but
the team doesn't want to pay him so he
doesn't want to be there if they don't
want to pay him yeah you know yeah I
mean he wants to be in Pittsburgh if
they pay him and that's the majority of
players in the National Football League
if you paid me I like Earl Thomas I will
be there but if you don't and you don't
want to pay me you just want to use me
then this is the attitude that I'm gonna
have against organization what do you
think of Earl Thomas though with being
upset yeah I mean I certainly understand
why he's upset I just wish he would have
handled it in it in a different manner
because you know Earl to me he got
caught up in his his emotions of what
he's feeling towards the team certainly
not for the players I think it's for the
organization and the way he felt like
he's been treated and so he's lost to me
you know that sense of what he means to
everybody else to young players his fans
people that look up to and his family
members that wasn't a good look for her
to leave the field in that manner do you
still hate the Patriots I don't I mean
you know it was something that that when
I played I you know I hated the patient
but I hated the Raiders too you know and
so that was just kind of a you know
something that when I played I was just
kind of built that way because I had so
many problems with the Patriots and the
Raiders for the for that matter but no I
mean I I've had an opportunity to really
respect what what they have done over
the years and it's really tremendous to
be able to have that long of a run that
many championships to do it consistently
that's what any player wants and you
gotta admire with what those guys have
done who goes farther this year the Rams
are the Chargers
okay I think the Charger's do and I'll
tell you why I think the Charger's it
they're gonna get going obviously like
they always do as a season progressed
but I think their Road is much easier
now if Kansas City wins that division
which is it looks like they're going to
end up doing that I think the Chargers
their role to run deep in the playoffs
will be much easier because to me that
AFC is easier the NSC is yeah oh man you
got you got 617 that you can you can say
that possibly has a chance of going to
the Superbowl still waiting for your
Vikings Jersey that you promised me a
couple of years ago got it I know you do
I still got it
I'm just waiting I'm waiting on you Wow
no to invite me you know to a charity
event or something that you're doing
that you know justjust let's be friends
but just be friends I don't want to be
friends I just wanted the Jersey LT I
mean that's asking a lot you can't get
to Jersey without being friends
how about acquaintances okay okay here's
the deal at the Super Bowl in Atlanta
we're gonna have you on set and you know
we can make it a big production we could
have a band there you know it can be
like a spotlight you know whatever you
know that sounds great but I'll tell you
what like like we always do you have
your people talk to my great to catch up
with the LT thanks for joining us always
a pleasure thank you that's a little
edenian Tomlinson I think the first time
we had him on he was still in college
yes right before the Heisman yeah and we
always I just loved his attitude and
then man you look at those numbers
who he put up some numbers there and
that's why he's a hall-of-famer for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show at
you
[Music]